I'm like this with my mom too though
what what are you like we're trying to
grab like dinner or lunch every two
weeks and it should be like
we're at IHOP enjoying this strawberry
pancakes just enjoy the goddamn fruity
there he's like this is living baby why
can't you focus on your
look at all the different kind of syrups
we have here we have butter pecan we're
on Atlantic and you're thinking about
Cerritos man up Mom that's the funniest
phrase you get embarrassed when she
starts crying she's like hey stop crying
stop crying you do that no and then I go
home I tell Gio what happened she
yells at me
we're on Cerritos we're not in Atlanta